Grace: Okay.
Hannah: Okay.
Look how long our arms look.
*laughing gasps*
Grace: We're not on drugs.
*bouncy noise*
Grace: It's the guest of honor Ricky Dillon!
*spring noise*
*cheering*
Ricky: Hello!
Grace: In honor of all of us making a video together,
I wanted to do something that Hannah, Mamrie and I did with Tyler,
which was go through his old Instagram photos. So-
Ricky: Oh no!
*laughter*
Grace: I've pulled some of Ricky Dillon's old Instagram photos-
Ricky: Ohhhh, I wasn't prepared for this! Alright.
Grace: -for all of us to look through right now.
Ricky: *sarcastic* Yay.
Mamrie: We have a bottle of Vodka if you need it.
Grace: Okay, so we'll start here.
Ricky: Oh wow that's all artsy!
Grace: Yeah, this is from February 18th 2013.
Ricky: I was still at college.
Grace: 'Filming, haha, i thought i looked pretty cool'.
Ricky: I took a picture in front of a light box.
Grace: Oh, that's what that is in the background.
Mamrie: So this when he started like, art.
Ricky: This is when I kicked off my career.
Grace: Were you-
Ricky: I'm not embarrassed by this one.
Grace: No wait there. Don't worry, we'll get there.
I mean this is better than what I could do. When they had filters come out for the first time,
I was like Oh My God, I am a genius!
Ricky: Look the comments are nice, like-
Grace: So nice!
Hannah: That's great.
Ricky: -I killed that one.
Mamrie: *breathy laugh*
Grace: Okay, here's your next one.
*chorus of 'woah's*
Grace: 'I got some modelling shots done today'.
You have a very extensive wig collection.
Ricky: Oh, they're over there.
I wish I could say I've outgrown this, but I haven't.
Mamrie: I love this bottom right because you look exactly like the guy from LMFAO.
Grace: LMFAO!
*'what?! sound effect*'
*laughter*
Ricky: That's Sheldon. That's a character I used to do.
Grace: I like 'Ricky Minaj'.
*oooh!*
Ricky: I used to have a little alter ego.
Wow, wow, flashback.
Mamrie: Okay, it's such a baby!
Grace: I know, so young!
Okay here we go moving on.
Ricky: Oh fun!
Awww, when I met Shane!
Grace: 2012! This is five years ago?!
Ricky: Yeah my first VidCon.
Grace: This is your first VidCon?
Ricky: And I standed in a huge line to wait to meet Shane.
Grace: Shane doesn't go to conventions anymore.
Ricky: Yeah! That was like-
Grace: So this is like a rare Pokémon that you found!
Ricky: Yes!
I met you at this VidCon too.
I wasn't a guest yet, so like I snuck into a party with friend,
and I was annoying and went around and met everybody.
Hannah: That does not guarantee that-
Ricky: Yeah don't do that!
*laughter*
Ricky: Don't do that!
Mamrie: If you got these arms, do whatever you want.
Hannah: Ricky, you look so buff!
Grace: I know!
Ricky: Thanks.
Ricky: He tweeted like, 'last-minute meet-and-greet, come' and I sprinted.
Grace: Here we go. This is 2012, throwback pick number one. What is-
Hannah: *gasps*
Mamrie: We got a shark tooth.
Ricky: I was showing transformation
The two on the left were from like high school, I was like 16 probably.
Grace: Oh my God!
Ricky: And then those were whenever this was, so-
Grace: 2012.
Mamrie: You look great in both, you just figured out Valencia.
*laughter*
Grace: So are these puka shells and then a shark tooth?
Mamrie: That's a shark tooth maybe.
Ricky: I was at the beach, so I bought some stuff i guess.
Hannah: That was a-
*laughter*
Mamrie: You know when you get to the beach and you're like, 'bought a necklace', then immediately putting it on'.
Hannah: Uh, bought three necklaces. Immediately put all three of them on!
Ricky: This was homecoming.
Hannah/Grace: Awww!
Grace: And where are these other two shirtless ones? You forgot to wear shirts when you grew up.
Mamrie: *noise of agreement*
Ricky: Yeah, i had a really like, tool phase like that.
Mamrie: I think you look adorable. You definitely look like the hottest boy at church camp.
Hannah/Grace: Yeah, yeah!
*laughter*
Hannah: That's also the hottest boy in church camp.
Mamrie: That guy's name is Brad.
Grace: He's the counsellor at church camp.
*laughter*
Grace: This is-
Ricky: Oh fun!
Mamrie: Oh my goodness!
Grace: So this is 2012 and this is-
I thought all of O2L- but who is that one?
Ricky: So, Ricardo was in O2L for a little bit.
Mamrie: What?!
Hannah: Ricardo?!
Grace: This is like the first iteration of Destiny's Child.
Ricky: And that was right after VidCon, we had all met for the first time.
This week was when we decided to make O2L.
Hannah: Wait okay, so who's that?
Grace: That's Sam Pottorff.
Ricky: Sam.
Hannah: No! *disbelieving*
Grace: Yeah, and look that's Connor!
Hannah: NO! *in shock*
Mamrie: You look like just boys on a cul-de-sac about to solve a summer mystery.
*laughter*
Grace: You look like an Abercrombie & Fitch commercial.
Hannah: Yeah.
Grace: Look at this-
Ricky: Oh fun!
*laughter*
Ricky: This is our-  us moving to LA together.
Grace: Yeah.
Ricky: I was in Florida with my family,
Connor flew down, we picked up JC in Texas, and so we did across the country.
Grace: You drove across the country?!
Hannah: No way!
Ricky: In my tiny Kia Soul, all of our stuff. I don't know how we did that.
Hannah: Look at Connor Franta-
Grace: The bracelets are killing me!
Hannah: The tongue!
Grace: The hair!
Mamrie: Those sunglasses, boo.
Ricky: I was gonna say my sunglasses.
Mamrie: You look like a third base coach had a baby with Guy Fieri.
*laughter*
Grace: Mamrie, calling it like it is!
Mamrie: I'm just sayin'.
Ricky: No I agree, I was about to say, 'those need to get off'.
That was a crazy road trip.
So, we got pulled over, they thought we had drugs in the car, so they had to search my car
and it was full of all of our stuff.
We hit a bird, which was sad.
We broke down in the middle of the desert, so we were like:
'oh we'll get gas eventually', but then nothing ever came and we ran out of gas in the middle of the desert.
But it was so scary. Their phones weren't working and mine barely did
so like, luckily I was able to call, um, roadside or whatever.
Grace: Look at this!
Hannah: Awww.
Mamrie: Oh my goodness!
Grace: This is 2012...*reading caption* "Mirror pic at school, holla"
Hannah: Oh my God.
Grace: Look at you!
Mamrie: How old are you there?
Ricky: Wow.
Mamrie: What year is this?
Ricky: I'm in college. I was 20. 2012?
Hannah: You're so adorable.
Grace: And this is before front-facing cameras.
Ricky: Yeah!
Grace: When we all had to take the photos in the mirror like that.
Mamrie: Look how dated this is: *reading a comment* "No, not 'holla' it's 'YOLO'"
*laughter*
Ricky: *reading comment* "You so awkward." ...yeah.
Ricky: *reading comment* "Your shorts make it look like you have extremely pointy knees."
Grace: *laughs* What?!
Hannah: That's nice!
Grace: I don't think see that as a bad thing.
Hannah: Yeah! Yum...
*record scratch sound effect*
Grace/Mamrie: Yum?!
Grace: *laughs*
Mamrie: What a weird...
Ricky: Did you say "yum"?
Grace: Yes!
Grace: Okay, here's one more-
Mamrie: He looks so little!
Grace: -that we got.
Ricky: This is one of my first Instagram pictures ever.
Grace: Yeah, this is 2011.
Hannah: *reading caption* "What it is". *laughs*
Mamrie/Grace: *reading caption* "What it is".
Ricky: People scroll down and find this all the time.
Mamrie: I love it.
Hannah: They do?
Ricky: Yeah, 'cause I think it's my first one.
Grace: Remember we all did the rounded edges?
Mamrie: 'Instamatic'!
Ricky: This filter...
Grace: Yeah, Instamatic! Yeah.
Ricky: I'm like, I'm like ... three pixels.
Mamrie: *laughing* "I'm like three pixels"!
Hannah: *slow motion* Pickles?!
Mamrie: *laughing*
Grace: It also looks like someone is peeking in your window through your blinds.
*gasps*
Mamrie: It totally does!
Hannah: That's creepy! ... It 100% does.
Grace: There's Connor just creeping on your style.
Mamrie: *imitating Connor* "You wanna start a group?"
Grace: Go back to Ricky's Instagram, scroll down, find this photo...
Ricky: Find this... Go comment on it!
Grace: Leave a comment!
Ricky: Make it my most liked photo ever.
*oooh*s
Grace: That's a lofty-
Mamrie: How about everyone put "I see you, @ConnorFranta"?
*gasps and laughter*
Hannah/Grace: Yes!
Hannah: So, this is like a hardcore like, 'bro' phase?
Ricky: Yeah, I guess I had a weird, like, backwards hat...
Hannah: Sideways!
Ricky/Grace: Sideways...
Hannah: The 90s are alive and well in 2011.
Grace: Hey ... you committed to a style.
Ricky: Yeah.
Grace: And we all- look, we've all- look back at all of us.
Mamrie: No, don't do that.
Grace: Uh, but make sure you guys go check out everyone's channel here
because we made videos on every single one of them,
um, and they're really fun. And I mean we shot one already
but I'm assuming the rest were fun.
Ricky: They're gonna be fun.
Hannah: Fingers crossed!
Grace: Go check those out and go check out Ricky's Instagram because
there's a lot of great gems that I didn't even bring up.
Ricky: Yeah, this was a trip.
Grace: Uh, other than that, I don't know.
Hannah: You should make 'Rocky Dillon' and do like your... I don't know.
Ricky: Like an alter-ego?
Hannah: Yeah. *laughs*
Grace: I mean *laughs*
Ricky: Oh, like a- oh fun! A new character!
Grace: There you go.
Ricky: Rocky Dillon...
Grace: Ah well, this has been fun! Hannah's gonna continue to brainstorm some...
mild ideas for characters.
Mamrie: If you ever need Hannah to make a character
where she switches out one letter of your name...
Hannah: Call me! ... Wait until you guys meet 'Honnah Hart'!
*laughter*
Ricky: Wow, 'Honnah'.
Grace: "Honnah Hart"?
Hannah: *to Ricky* Thanks!
Ricky: 'He-nnah"!
Hannah: "He-nnah"! Pound this.
Grace: OK, I'll let you guys brainstorm.
Mamrie: Should we leave?